Kelly and Conway counsel to the
president this this helps Donald Trump
tonight this is a big big beginning to
the end of what has been a which on from
pretty much day one so Shawn this week
we had the Comey book and now tonight we
finally have a Comey blockbuster that
actually would interest and animate the
public what you just revealed is truly
remarkable and breathtaking on many
different levels you revealed what the
president what Comey thought the
president was asking him to do and most
importantly not what he what Comey
claims the president was asking him to
do and I think the most remarkable thing
about what you just revealed is that
this is a president who from the
beginning has been compliant and
transparent and has never gotten in the
way of this investigation what's
remarkable to me this week is you know
30 days of Comey is going to be about 29
and a half days too much and he's
already not wearing well on this
so-called book tour for somebody to name
his book lies and leadership what's the
lies is he talking about
Andrew McCabe was number two who just
had a criminal referral tonight he was
admitted now is it admitted liar what
leadership what leadership when the
people at the highest level who are
investigating Hillary Clinton aren't
even bothering to tell the FISA Court
judge that her political enemies have
funded that phony dossier to the tunes
of millions and millions of dollars and
in the case of James Comey why didn't he
how we can present early thump on
January 6 in Trump Tower right but why
did he just write it on his hands what
I'm going to tell the president fought
her eggs oh your political opponents
funded the dossier didn't even bother to
tell them that told George
Stephanopoulos story this week well I I
can't answer that question it wasn't
part of my goals it's phony all the way
and the fact that you released I think
we should go on a a Comey memo tour
let's do that let's go to the cony memo
tour instead of a Comey book tour
because that's where the truth lies you
know but but but Kelly the seriousness
of what they have put this country
through now he leaked Adams
I'm not sneaky I don't leak BS he'll eat
and he'd leak for the perfect
he admitted under the special counsel
but you add everything together hilary
obstructed justice they protected her as
mark was saying earlier tonight
absolutely because she committed crimes
that is a fact it's irrefutable and it's
been Shawn and they thought she'd win
we'd never know any of this
and they thought she'd win they wanted
her to Hillary would win except us
that's really important here because we
would know none of this we would know
none of this unless if Hillary Clinton
had actually won which Comey admitted he
was influenced by the phony baloney
national media polls out of the way
right anybody was doing national polls
the statewide polls were relevant as you
know that's what we did at the campaign
but more importantly we would know none
of this we would we would not know that
the people at the highest levels
investigating Hillary Clinton had the
fix in for her and against Trump against
a candidate Trump but let these memos
out there people have been calling for
transparency and accountability and
continuing investigations for over a
year look people have called into
question Jim Comey's credibility and
everything this week that's fine but I'm
grasping with his essential relevance at
this point in this book the relevance to
Jim Comey is probably in these memos not
in the book this is somebody who hardly
knew the president he's knitted together
limited limited amount of time this now
needs to end for the sake of the country
kelly-ann good to see you great points
as always